in London and other suspect is in
custody in connection with a homophobic
attack on two women on a bus
investigators say a group of teenagers
assaulted the couple believed to include
an American last week now one of the
women is talking about the ordeal empty
as ty ab is live in London with the
latest MT has such a disturbing story
yeah very much so good morning well as
you say in the last few hours in this
very fast-moving investigation we've
heard that there's been a fifth arrest
in what London's Metropolitan Police are
calling a homophobic attack and robbery
now all of the young men in custody are
between the ages of 15 and 18 and are
currently being questioned by
investigators now just over a week ago
two women 28 year-old Melania hamona
and her partner 29 year old Chris who we
understand his American were travelling
on a city bus where they were assaulted
by a group of men after they allegedly
refused to kiss each other on demand the
next thing I know is that Chris is in
the middle of the bus and they are
punching her so I immediately went there
just you know by impulse I didn't think
about it and I tried to pull her out of
there so they started punching me I
don't remember if I was trying to get
her out or I punch at somebody I
actually I read on so they started
beating me till I was like bleeding all
over now both required medical treatment
as a result of the attack according to
police reported homophobic hate crimes
across London have almost doubled over
the past four years and in a lengthy
post on social media the couple
defiantly announced they would not be
intimidated into hiding their sexuality
and blamed the rise of what they
described as quote right-wing populism
for the growth in hate crimes no
Britain's Prime Minister Theresa May
said the assault was sickening and
London's Mayor Sadiq Khan called it a
disgusting misogynistic attack now today
also happens to be the first day of
pride bump here in the UK which of
course is a celebration of lgbtq+
heritage but that image of two women
left
bruised and bloodied allegedly because
of their sexuality and one of the most
accepting cities in the world will no
doubt be a sobering reminder to many
that the fight against intolerance is
far from over
Michelle reminds us clearly of that very
fact and yes such an upsetting story
yeah yeah I'm glad they have some
suspects